he will talk about pdeon graphs and
their continue
continuation limits welcome
thank you very much uh i'm really very
happy to be here uh you know as many
speakers in our first uh or not speakers
participants uh first conference i
wouldn't say after the pandemics but uh
you know after a long while
and uh i have learned really a lot uh in
this boot camp about areas that i
knew uh very little about previously
and uh i'll keep my talk also somehow
uh rather basic so i really want this to
be somehow boot camp and kind of clear
you know so that people from other areas
who might be interested in this can
still kind of get the gist and maybe get
the idea about how some of the
techniques work so please you know feel
free to stop me uh i don't have a kind
of a big goal at the end to
reach and uh
i'm you know
happy to discuss this
so okay um we we said something about 3d
on graphs so these are motivated by uh
graph learning so what is kind of a
typical setup right so typical setup is
that one has a
sample of some points right which uh in
the space right and uh
you know these may be samples of you
know these digits from the end this data
set that uh jose antonio was showing
right or maybe some you know medical
records and so on
uh it may be that these points lie in a
very high dimensional space right but
somehow
uh
if problems are genuinely intrinsically
high dimensional then they are typically
statistically intractable usually there
is some lower dimensional structure
that
we can exploit to make uh you know
statistically reliable uh inferences so
uh you know the question is how do we
access that low-dimensional structure
and somehow the viewpoint of graph
graph-based learning is that uh we can
create the a graph out of these data
points somehow to capture some of the
geometric information so what is
happening is that uh you know one is uh
connecting points one is connecting
nearby points right and uh this okay so
i put too many points right but i you
know uh
you have to choose a length scale right
and then uh
based on that length scale you create
your graph and how to choose this length
scale is you know it's not uh you know
it's difficult in itself but let's say
that you were able to choose a
reasonable length scale so that your
graph
on some level captures the geometry of
the underlying measure from which the
data are sampled right so okay so the
object now that we have we have these
vertices so i have you know xn is the
set of vertices x1 up to well update so
maybe script x and up to x n so these
are vertices and we have some weights so
w i j
is the edge weights
okay then there are many somehow
algorithms right so
you know just write two which are
you know not in kind of entirely
reasonable right but resemble those that
are really used and are kind of going to
be helpful for me in posing the uh
analysis task so okay maybe one one of
the tasks that one wants to do is uh
clustering right so we would like to see
if so this is a you know typical uh
problem in
unsupervised learning we want to see if
there is some signal in the structure of
the data itself right so what is a
cluster it's very hard to define
axiomatically right but we would like to
say these are somehow clumps in the data
right we want to you know if if the data
really all looked like this
right if this is
my set of points right then we would
easily identify somehow two clusters
right so these are all close by there is
a significant margin between them if i
have something like this well then you
may say okay so here
here there may be a you know relatively
dense region of points and here they may
be a relatively dense region of points
and okay these points in between could
be taught in some ways or some outliers
right but the question is really how do
i now quantify this when i don't have
really separated clusters and so on and
there are various energies that one can
think of and let's say the one that uh
comes from spectral clustering would be
the following so we introduce an
objective functional
that uh
acts on functions on these graphs so
basically i'll have a function u that
will take this graph into real line okay
and if i
you know for this function u
uh let's say we write the energy as the
sum of w i j
u at x i which i'm going to write as u i
minus u j so this is basically this
short for u of x i
uh
let's say squared and okay i put a sum
here and this is a double sum so i goes
from one to n and j goes from one to n
okay so okay this is just you know what
is uh
uh a graph a now zone of uh dirichlet
energy right so how can we use this for
uh and i'll just be looking at by
clustering so clustering dividing into
you know somehow uh two sets so
maybe what i would like to do is okay so
if i want uh
well i noticed that for this energy
right if i choose a constant function
right so the smoothest function right so
then the energy is going to be equal to
zero right
so okay then we would like to see okay
what is the smoothest function which is
orthogonal to uh
to a constant right so what if i
minimize so let's say uh
i don't know u bar is
argument
well this is a convex problem so
it is uh
the minimizer is unique right well sorry
ah it's not
right
when i add a constraint then no longer
right so let's say among all u's which
are perpendicular so to one so the dot
product with one is equal to zero and i
minimize this energy
so
e of u
so now i'm having a function which has
average zero right and it's such that
kind of its variation right you know the
gradients measured in this quadratic
norm should be as small as possible
right so how will this function look
like well uh
my guess is that uh what this function
will do is uh if i look at this function
over
you know something i plot it in one
dimension right so that on this cluster
over here it's going to be negative then
it's going to very quickly transition in
this region here because here there are
very few connections in this graph so
there are very few weights it is very
cheap to transition here from this
negative value to the positive value and
okay let's say you know truth just do
you know you can there are many
minimizes but let's say i normalize it
so that uh
uh it's normalized to have the l2 norm
equal to one right then you hope to
obtain a function like this and let's
say the clusters are the sets where u is
positive or the set where uh u is
negative okay so
yeah
uh yeah so indeed right i didn't define
well how my w is going to depend on x
but yes right let's use them to
use them
that's right yes
yeah that's that's a
quite important remark right that the
geometry right you know the way that the
geometry comes in right when i created
this graph is in this place w and let me
actually address this somehow right away
so there are two typical ways uh to
define these graphs so one is you know a
random geometric graph which means that
i'm going to choose some uh kernel
function let's say function eta
uh
which you know could be a constant
function and then dropping down to zero
uh and uh we will set the weight so w i
j to be just eta of the distance between
the nodes x i and x j right
so
this is you know if i choose this then
you exactly attain a random geometric
graph so you connect things if they are
within this length scale l right so this
is like choosing this blank scale
whereas here i still have a length scale
right which is
kind of you know the first moment of
this data
but it does so in a soft way okay and uh
you know very often one would take a
gaussian to prove some and they make
some statements kind of rigorous right
it will be easier for me to take a
compactly supported uh data so i'm going
to look at ada which is supported on the
interval from zero to uh from zero to
one another kind of typical construction
is to look at the k n graphs which means
that you just connect every node with k
of its neighbors right where instead of
choosing uh yeah
you know length scale l right you choose
the number of neighbors right
then the proofs the you know kind of the
theoretical setup is similar to what i
will be you know saying so everything
can be done for those graphs of course
the models are somewhat different you
know the the graphs that you obtain you
know look different and for many things
k n graphs are actually
somewhat better in practice but i will
stick with uh kind of the graphs that
i'll obtain over here and i'll also say
okay so to
you know be able to explicitly state the
length scale that i'm going to be using
right i'm actually gonna define you know
the typical mollifier scaling so let eta
epsilon uh
of z
be equal to
one over epsilon to the d
where uh
okay i'll i have i'll have a comment of
that but uh okay eta of uh
z or epsilon
right so okay
d you know the dimension d that i should
be using if the data on the manifold
then these should be the intrinsic uh
dimension of the data so you can say
well wait but i don't know what that is
well
i do this more of as a mathematician
because my minimizer right will be the
same whether i have this absolute d or
not right but i'm using such scaling
where the limit as n and epsilon go to
you know as n goes to infinity and
epsilon goes to zero where i will be
obtaining a reasonable limit right so
and also
uh
you know while one can do everything
when data really lie on a manifold right
i'm gonna mostly stick with the
kind of the data being somehow full
dimension because it's just easier to
write things we don't have to use the
notation a lot of the language of
differential geometry okay so
all right so you know something this is
one model that uh i will be considering
right so
you know energy is like this right and
minimizing such energies let me
introduce another model which i'm
actually going to study first and this
other one is uh really fake but uh
uh
but you know again this is just for
pedagogical uh uh purposes to see
somehow uh
showcase some of the techniques that can
then be applied to kind of uh
uh more relevant problems so imagine
that instead of so the second problem is
okay so again i have uh my points
right
and
uh let's assume that there is a subset
of points right
on which i know what my
uh on which i have some information so
let's say what is information maybe
i want to somehow assign some label
right so you know i'm deciding right you
know kind of what is the likelihood that
this is an image of a cancerous uh
lesion right versus that it is not so i
have some and if i'm in some regions
then i know what the answer is supposed
to be and now i would like to propagate
that answer
over the some of the geometry of this
data right so let's say then my label
right so this u would be given so i know
that this u or this set so let's say
there exists some set you know capital u
over which i know that my function u
should be equal to some function g so or
this set u is given right
so you know in that sense i would like
to do the following right so i wanna
uh
you know i will be only looking at
function u which maps uh this script x
and without uh you know those indices x
i
uh which lie in the set u
so those are
not gonna be free to
assign and i'd like to minimize so the
task is to minimize
uh
you know efu
subject to constraints
that
well actually right so i should okay
maybe i
right sorry
let me write it like this this maps u uh
this into r
uh so okay i look at the function which
is free everywhere but uh i add this as
a constraint that uh you know restricted
to those nodes you know script x
intersected u
is
gonna be equal to g
so on some subset of my nodes my
function is given
right then i would like to minimize uh
this and i would say okay if i uh
yeah
i would like to
[Music]
right uh highlight that okay
if this is you know if i use that w of i
and j is equal to eta epsilon of uh x i
minus x three so this is the eta
absolutely you know these are the ways
that i'll be using right so then it
makes sense that i add indices uh
epsilon and n to my energy right because
given a number of points my energy is
gonna be uh taking a different shape
okay uh
and uh
well we know that okay so i'm not going
to somehow quite do that but uh
you know this is a you know simple
quadratic functional i could do the
first variation and write what is the
oil lagrange equation and if i do that
right what i will obtain right is the
first of the condition is that you know
for every i
right i'll have that the sum over j
of you know w i j
of u i
minus uh u j
is going to be
equal to zero and this would be for
every i again lying in this
uh set you know
so x i does not lie the mu right
not fine
okay uh well
uh this is what i will call the graph
laplacian right so i say let's open
maybe a change then
so
evaluated right okay here i'm gonna
write explicitly x i right
would be you know the
sum of j of eta epsilon of
x i minus x j
uh
u at x i denoted by ui minus qj
okay so
in this case right and i have the
constraint again that you know you
restricted to the set u okay is going to
be equal to g again this is u
okay so i have these two prototypical
problems right so let's say this is uh
you know the first problem here is this
variational problem and the second
problem is uh you know something that
looks like an elliptic equation on a
graph
of use uh no no no this is just uh when
i do the first variation right then i
obtain the graph laplacian right and you
write my equation my i didn't write the
first order condition
right that this guy is gonna be equal to
zero thanks
okay uh
so now the question is right
you know if we are having a reasonable
statistical procedure right then it
should be the case that uh
if my data are really sampled out of
some manifold or some measure on a
manifold right so
in this case right now what i will be
assuming right is that there exists an
underlying manifold
or which you know the geometric aspect
in kind of in this stock will be
restricted to saying right that there
exists a set omega in uh
r to the d so it will be a full
dimension again everything can be done
in manifolds it's just more complicated
to write down
uh there exists a set of uh full
dimension such that all of these points
here x i are random samples of a measure
mu
and uh you know omega is describing the
support of this measure mu okay and you
know the kind of the assumption that we
need right for
uh for our theorems which is not
entirely reasonable right but kind of as
the first step is that
uh this measure mu is absolutely
continuous with respect to
uh the big measure which would be then
you know it's absolute continuous with
respect to volume form on a manifold and
uh this row has the property that it's
bounded above and below by positive
constants right so
c1 which is positive and
c2 again the this second one could be
removed but this first one is uh
difficult to remove uh in the setting
here
so we assume that kind of measure does
not degenerate
on its support
and uh now the question is if i'm
drawing uh you know a different sample
or perhaps i draw more and more points
is my statistical procedure going to be
stable right am i going to be obtaining
somehow similar answer so this is this
continuum limit this is the consistency
question for on the level of this uh
in this case you know quadratic
variational problem in this case a
linear equation right but one could ask
with these you know
the second technique that they'll ask
one can treat actually also
uh
non-linear and non-convex problems in
terms of kind of
finding the minimum
and deciding whether the procedure
because the minimum is the answer to our
procedure so again
my you know the main question that i
would like to address is that
whether as n goes to infinity
uh these procedures converge and to
identify what do they converge to and
you know maybe discuss somehow more or
less the general setup of that
okay so that's kind of the
uh you know the topic of this talk uh
right
okay so
before i kind of move on right so i just
recall you know how do we you know
how do we you know connect what is
happening in
a discrete
uh
point cloud where it's a random discrete
point cloud and what would be happening
in a queuing right so there will be you
know uh kind of three levels that i'll
do that right so first i'm going to look
at the a fixed smooth function right i'm
going to plug in that smooth function
into this laplacian into the graph of
washing and see how much it resembles uh
laplacian on
this underlying set the second thing
would be what happens at the level of
the solutions of a pd right because
it you know i don't know the solution of
the graph pd i don't you know how
exactly it relates to solution then it's
the function is different and i would
like to obtain estimates on the
difference of these two functions and
the third
thing would be what happens if i look at
minimizers of variational problems okay
so for the first task when i'm looking
at the fixed function right this is
somehow pretty classical right i'm you
know we are looking at the empirical
estimate on some sum
uh related to that function it's more or
less like a monte carlo integral
uh but okay let me somehow write down
how that is uh done and you know one of
the tools that we need for that are
concentration equalities right of course
that's a big field in itself there are
various concentration equalities adapted
to different situations i'm just gonna
recall one
uh you know perhaps one of the oldest
ones and uh
you know applied in on one of the
problems over here
and uh again just scratch the surface of
that very big field right so you know
let's look at bernstein inequality
so let's say assume that uh so this is
all in r so you know we have x one x and
our uh
you know random variables with values in
r
right so
variables
so i derive variables this is not a good
idea
okay we have that they have finite
expectation rate so
and for mean right then they have uh
they are also bounded uh you know
something like l infinity right so
their uh distance to expectation
is a
lesser equal than some finite number b
and let's say d is the variance right so
this is the expectation of
x i minus m
squared right in that case let me look
at sn which is the
uh you know just the sum of
these variables so x1 plus
and right then what we have is that the
probability
that
the average of the sum
deviates from mean by more
than a positive number t
is less or equal than
e to the
minus n
t squared divided by
two times variance plus okay i'm you
know here not putting the optimal
constants because i i don't need them
but uh
maybe it's something
like this so first of all so i somehow i
you know uh what do you expect let's say
from law of large numbers right you
expect that you know the typical
distance of
you know the average of the average to
the mean is going to be like square root
of n and indeed you could see that you
know if you know p is uh you know less
than some constant times one or square
root of n right
then you exactly get here you know one
over n times n right so this can only be
small right if t is less than some
constant times one over square root of
two so you see that it's exactly that
length scale or you know in terms of n
right
from law of large numbers when
this probability can be expected to be
significantly less than one right and
then okay if i have that t
is uh a lot less than one over square
root of n then i can expect that
uh this probability is going to be very
very small right so here we are of
course interested in pro you know i want
to make sure that something happens with
high probabilities we would indeed be
interested in those regimes where this
can be made
as small as i like you know let's say
less than one over n to the fourth or
something of that flavor
v is
v is the variance
so it's the same
variance
huh no no they are all id right so i
just wrote i because
right
yeah this is a simple form of you know
of course there are right uh
okay
well
then let's look at this uh
graph look lush and select and create
some space
so
right well
instead of you know writing it like this
okay let me go back to
writing as
u of x i
minus u of x j
and uh okay
so
you know here i just uh use this as a
definition for
uh the laplacian right but uh i okay now
you know as soon as i wrote it right i'm
gonna
uh change it a little bit because i'm
interested in
kind of uh limits again
uh all right so i didn't really quite
explain right but uh
uh
as n goes to infinity so i get more and
more points right it is natural to take
epsilon to go to zero for various
reasons so
epsilon you came out of necessity right
because uh we needed to connect the
nearby points to recover the geometry if
i have more and more points i can you
know recover the geometry at a higher
resolution
and i don't want to connect points which
are too far so epsilon should scale in
some way with n okay that's one thing so
absolutely you should think of going to
zero as n goes to infinity and n goes to
infinity because that's the problem that
i set out to study what happens if i get
more and more uh data points
okay so
since i want to take those limits i want
to scale things in such a way that they
will make sense in that limit so i'm
going to divide this by
one over n
epsilon squared and i'm actually gonna
there is also one constant of
proportionality that depends on the
kernel data which i'm going to call
sigma eta and i'm also only going to
specify specified later but again this
is just a positive real number which
depends on area so given this
right uh
well i noticed that this seems to be
somehow uh an empirical somehow average
over a certain
function and what would that function be
so or operator b so this would be
if i have a function u
which is defined everywhere on omega
right then uh l epsilon of u would be
one over sigma
uh eta epsilon squared times the
integral
of uh
theta epsilon of uh
y minus x
u of y
minus u of x
and okay i have that the density
of
mu is rho so
rho x row y d
okay so you could see you know right
away from the definition right that uh
the mean of uh ln epsilon for any n
uh is nothing else but uh l epsilon of u
so given a function if i take a fixed
function u right then
this is nothing else but the mean and
let's see somehow what is the so
the way that i will connect the
uh
graph laplacian to the ordinary
laplacian is going to be in two stages
so first i get rid of just the
randomness but not of the length scale
epsilon right so first i'm going to
connect this with
uh an integral operator that still has
the length scale epsilon and then in the
next stage i'm going to
connect the
this non-local integral operator with
the actual laplacian right okay so
you know if we define uh
you know you define you know variables
yj
to be uh well okay let's forget about a
sigma for a second grid but i just
defined this to be
data of where
x j
states i so in this case i is fixed
and if i apply the
bernstein inequality and i don't have
quite you know it's it's satisfactory
really to uh
to go through the numbers but i feel
that i don't quite have time to do that
but you just apply well okay let me just
do a little bit of that right so this
eta epsilon so what is the maximum of
you know
uh so the mean of this is going to be
you know uh sigma eta times uh
l epsilon q but let's see what is the
size of this going to be bounded by and
let's say i'm taking a function u which
is a smooth function right so then the
size of this is going to be bounded by
well eta is a size one but then it
divided by epsilon to the d so this is
going to be one over epsilon to the d
plus two right but then here okay this
is like a gradient right
so this is going to be bounded then by
ellipses
constant in u then multiply how far can
these two points be within the support
of eta epsilon well support of eta right
is a size one when i rescale it it's a
size epsilon so i get one epsilon over
here and uh okay then you know the right
thing to do is just to adjust over there
and you do the similar exercise for
variance and what you basically obtain
is that
the difference so you apply by bernstein
uh it's going to tell you that uh
l
and epsilon of u minus l epsilon of u
is going to be
lesser equal than
lambda over 2
electric constant of u
with probability
one minus e to the
so
minus a small constant and
epsilon to the d plus 2
minus
okay and
there are kind of now variants of this
in a sense that
okay i just did it for one point if i
want to do it for all points at the same
time right then you could use something
like a union bound so you may obtain
something like ln of n or i think in
that estimate that including is three
times l of n
and then also
if you want to have this also somehow
for for every point on the set omega
even those points which are not somehow
sample points but you still would
evaluate the graph laplacian right then
you would need some uh
uh
partitioning somehow estimates so you
may have to pay a little bit of price
over there right so if i want to do this
uniformly against over uh sample and
also allow for to go out the sample then
okay i need to pay a little bit of price
but now okay this you know may seem like
a kind of an odd way to suppose this but
i want to you know i want to
look at uh two things so epsilon is
going to be small
and i have two options so first you know
uh just to see when can i make these
smalls okay so the boundary of the
region when things are small is when
lambda is of
size one right so i noticed you know to
interpret this you know if lambda is of
size one right then for this to be small
i need that epsilon is much bigger than
1 over n part d plus 2. and again i'm
not writing logarithms let's say i'm
neglecting maybe some logarithms but i'm
really just looking at some algebraic
scalings right so again uh
if i allow myself i just want you know
i'm at the boundary when i when i have
any approximations which is when lambda
is one
uh that will hold if epsilon is bigger
than uh
n uh well no this is not like this right
so this is one over d plus two right
and uh
the other is when i have a linear
approximation so i'm gonna take lambda
to be equal to epsilon so in that case
i'm gonna
write
so right you see here i have epsilon to
the power d plus four right so
uh i want you know then i'm gonna have
this with high probability if epsilon is
much bigger than 1 over
n to 1 over d plus
4.
okay and again i'm neglecting logarithms
because i need some logarithms so that
they get their powers of n
in the probability could you say one
more time uh what lambda is
oh lambda is a number that i choose
right so i'm choosing how accurate of an
approximation i want right so you know
the first thing is that i'm going to
have to have any uh you know
approximation i need lambda to be small
so i'm really choosing lambda at the
boundary of that region right so
basically
if epsilon is not bigger than this
you're not going to have anything right
then the you have too much randomness
right on the other hand if i want to
have linear estimates so now i'm going
to interested in kind of obtaining
quantitative estimates i'm going to be
neat uh working in regimes that look
like this right so this is kind of very
basic as to how many points do we need
per neighborhood so that we can get some
reliable somehow estimates okay and the
second uh
okay
uh the second thing is
now the second step is so this would be
you know
from uh random to non-local right so
this estimate is from random to
non-local right so
this would be
and okay now let's look at the other
estimates which would be
non-local
to local or differential
so let me consider you know like a lemma
right so let u be a c3 functional omega
and let's consider
a point uh you know x such that uh
distance from x to boundary omega is
bigger than epsilon right so i do not
want uh my non-local operator to go
outside
in that case
we have that uh
this uh
non-local guy
so
l epsilon of u
uh minus uh so
right so
yeah so note that right these operators
right this guy here right is a positive
semi-definite so i'm really looking at
the negative laplacian right so you know
then gonna have plus one over rho
divergence of uh
rho squared gradient of u
is going to be less
or equal than
uh
c times the
sum constant right
times c3 norm of u multiplied by epsilon
right and this is obtained okay so i'm
not going to go through this uh it's
also very enjoyable actually exercise
you do uh uh you know taylor expansion
on this right and i just want to note
that uh right there is gonna be a
cancellation rate somehow in the first
term so maybe just to observe that uh
you know when i integrate uh you know
data epsilon of x minus y times gradient
u of x and now
okay this is dotted with uh x minus y
and let's say you know i
uh you see you'll have also expansion in
in this term so row of x plus you know
gradient row at x
uh dotted with y minus x plus higher
order terms i'm not writing the whole
thing out i'm just because i need a
secondary term i just want to point out
the only thing that i'm pointing out is
that okay this term will give me
something so i'm going to forget about
it for now right and i integrate against
d y
note that uh
eta is an even function so i may not
have mentioned well i kind of did
because i define everything in kind of
as a radial kernel
uh
so i should really then write it like
that but note that this is an odd
function and this term drops off so
we'll only obtain the terms that have
either second derivatives of u or have
gradient of rho and those two terms
survive and you know you recover your
operator in the end and you recognize
that it's this operator over here okay
so again that's purely somehow calculus
exercise there is nothing to it but it's
still enjoyable to do it to see
exactly the operator that uh pops out
okay so
uh in conclusion right so i don't know
this is uh
maybe this is lemon one
and uh then this ought to be lemon two
uh so okay
let's say something when you combine
these two things you have that with high
profile
you know under the conditions on epsilon
right so under the conditions on epsilon
if function u is c3 then with high
probability
we have the following so uh
so okay let's say you know if uh
if uh epsilon is much bigger than one
over
n two one over d plus four and u is a c
three function
then
with high probability
we have that uh
l
and epsilon of u
uh
we have the maximum
over
on i going from one to n
of uh this guy here right evaluated x i
minus uh you know the lead the operator
over there
at x i
is going to be less than some of these
two terms so
i have you know c3 norm times epsilon
right and then i have you know something
like this all together this is less than
some constant times u
in c3 multiplied by well okay here i
took lambda you know this is the case
i'm just writing one statement for
lambda being equal to epsilon so then
here i'm just gonna have
uh epsilon
okay
so this is uh what we know about our
operator and then
well let's see how can we do this
to obtain
uh
the information as to how far is the
solution okay now the equation comes
back on
so i set this equal to zero
uh how close is this to connect to a
solution of a
differential of a pde
now that i have this consistency
estimate basically between my uh you
know discrete operator and the continuum
operator right then this is kind of
pretty standard uh we just need to use
some stability
let's say for these elliptic equations
we have the comparison principle that
can provide somehow the desired
stability in l infinity norm right so
yeah
is that supposed to be something
uh yeah great
i'm just having a little bit of trouble
seeing why there's a little square
inside there
uh yeah so okay so on one hand that
would come out of the uh
uh
right so on one hand that that will come
out of the expansion right on the other
hand is uh
we obtained this guy
as uh right so
uh
uh
we obtained this guy as the first
variation of the graph dirichlet energy
right and the graph directional energy
is a double sum and each of these sums
has one row in it right so this is where
two rows somehow you know you can see it
on the level of the variational
functional that due to the fact that
it's double sum there would be it would
be quadratic with respect to density and
then okay here it's kind of a little bit
hard to see on this level but then on
the level of that's why i was saying
that taylor is it taylor is uh kind of
satisfactory because you know it exactly
gives
you know the
right power over there
so
yeah
right so
okay maybe
i don't need bernstein anymore right so
let me write here you know this fact
from pd's
okay so
uh imagine that i'm actually solving a
pd on domain omega right
and that you know i say let gamma
be the boundary form again let's say
assume that this omega has
the the
regular enough boundary so that
uh
the
the standard
existence uniqueness theory works right
so
i know that okay let me look at you know
kind of a linear elliptic you know
l is uh
elliptic operator
so for example let's say l u is negative
1 over 0
divergence of rho squared
gradient u know that i'm not you know
most of pd people would not put a minus
sign but in viscosity community this
would be quite welcome
and uh
right then
i'm looking at the equation so okay i'm
looking at the equation l u is equal to
f let's say in omega and u is equal to g
on the boundary of omega
so this is my problem p
then i would say that some other
function let's say v
v
is a super solution
of p
of the problem p if we have that l v is
bigger or equal than f in
omega and that uh v is bigger or equal
than so i have both that v is bigger
equal than g
on the boundary of omega right and we
have a
analogous notion of a sub solution
if we just reverse
these
inequalities right and then kind of the
you know standard theory that uh sorry
the
senator theorem right that he learned in
uh
pd1 that on which the theory of
viscosity solution eventually is based
right is that
if
okay let's say w is a sub solution
and v is a super solution
then
we have that w of x is less or equal
than v of x
for all x given omega
okay so note that right what does the uh
you know the information from the
definition tells you it just tells you
that
v must be bigger than u
i mean g is between them on the boundary
and that inside right they have some
operator estimates but it doesn't tell
you anything about
how the values of v and w are related
right the comparison principle tells you
that uh then
uh
v must be lesser equal than a greater
equal than w everywhere somewhere in
domain and okay
note that this implies you know
so this immediately implies because u is
a solution so therefore both the sub
solution is super solution so
immediately get that uh
any solution right has to lie
between these two extremes okay
and i know that if i look at the graph
problem because
uh the operator on a graph is also
positive semi-definite you have the
comparison principle for the problem on
the graph so the analogous you know
definition and theorem also holds on the
graph okay
so
okay so
what is then the problem that i'd like
to study
okay so so they don't have to deal with
the normal boundary conditions i'm gonna
you know create a a super fake problem
right
uh which is somehow the following rate
is that
imagine that uh
okay so we have our domain
oh we got
right as usual right and now okay let's
say that i was able to identify
right the boundary
region
for omega right so i call this
you know gamma epsilon so the gamma
epsilon
be the set of those points such that the
distance from x to boundary from bigger
is less than epsilon right and okay so
i'm gonna be considering the continuum
problem is just this right so
uh
it's just that minus okay i don't need
one over row but i'm just writing the
functional rows with gradient u is equal
to zero
in omega and that u is equal to g
on
the boundary of omega
and i also have the graph problem
so if you like p and epsilon
which says that uh
l and
epsilon
you know at x i is equal to 0
for all x i line and omega without g
epsilon and i have that uh
u if you like and
here and epsilon
of x i is equal to
g at x i
uh for all x i y in
epsilon
right
okay and so if we have this then
okay we can
write uh the following right so
yeah let me write some for the full
statement so let's consider lambda to be
less or equal than one
then we have that the maximum
or you know all x i
lying in
well over all of the x i's in the sample
u and epsilon of x i minus u of x i
where u is this now the solution of the
equation right so this is very different
than the setting that we had for the
point wise estimate right because i have
two distinct problem i solve each of
them separately and now i compare
the 2 right so this is going to be
lesser equal than the c times
u in c3 multiplied by
lambda plus
epsilon and this holds with probability
one minus uh
some level constant c exponent
negative another constant uh
n
epsilon of d plus 2
lambda squared plus
so again right
we need uh
we need uh
you know again you know if i want lambda
to be a size epsilon right or equal to
epsilon then i need uh epsilon to be
much bigger than 1 over and raise the
power
b plus 4. okay now how does how do we
prove this
using the comparison principle
okay so
on the level of the continuum pd i know
how to create super solution that will
stay a little bit above the actual
solution okay and then i will show that
i could use those continuous super
solutions to create discrete super
solutions so if i
down sample the continuum super solution
to the discrete spec
space then
these estimates
right will be enough you know these
estimates will tell me how much of the
super i need in order to have a discrete
super solution and then i will know that
my discrete solution is between somehow
the two okay so that's basically the
whole recipe and uh
okay let's just somehow carry it out so
let's say let
i need a barrier function so
let 5 be the solution of the following
so okay i'm going to call
okay
i call this operator uh
delta rho right
so let's like call solve negative delta
rho of uh
i
is equal to 1 between omega
and phi is equal to 0
other omega
now it's easy to show that uh
the minimum of phi has to be reached on
the boundary and therefore phi is
positive omega
okay and uh
right
and then okay so
i know that uh
you know if i consider this but here is
my you know the function that i'm going
to be looking at so i look at mu plus
delta times phi and then i add plus some
you know epsilon times the ellipses
constant of g so let's assume that g
the boundary data our ellipse is
continuous right so what is that i do
here right so
i create a little bit of a super
solution and i lift the data to account
for the fact that uh
the boundary data are not assigned
exactly on the same set right so here
it's just on the boundary whereas here
is in this uh thickened layer so i wanna
kind of make sure that i stay above that
and note that uh the maximum yeah so the
maximum the g can deviate away from the
boundaries
you know exactly by somehow this amount
so
it should be enough to have a super
solution so note that uh
this guy solves the equation you know if
i call this i don't know uh
u
i i just call it u delta
note that then what we have is that
uh rho of u delta is equal to delta in
omega
and that uh
okay if you like u plus
uh
delta phi right is equal to g
on omega okay so on boundary from again
it didn't really write this is a
solution of a problem because you know
here i just lifted this
even uh more somehow on the boundary so
if you like i just remember these two
facts somehow as separate facts
right then okay now
i want to show that this when i uh
restrict it to the discrete set is going
to be a super solution so what we have
is that uh
l epsilon n
of okay i write the whole thing so u
plus uh
delta phi plus
epsilon times the ellipses constant
of
g
well okay this is just a constant right
so i don't really need it when uh it
doesn't make any difference whether it's
there or not when evaluating the
graph laplacian right so okay what do we
get here so i get uh
you know minus
rho delta of uh
right so
okay i know that this guy
right this guy is precisely this guy
here applied to u plus delta phi right
so it should be this applied to u plus
delta phi so i get uh you know
this applied to u plus delta phi
right and what is the worst that can
happen right so at first i'm gonna have
an error like that so minus okay now i
have to say i stated this only for
lambda being equal to epsilon let me try
to recover there
uh
so i'm going to have you know
c times okay u
in c3 plus actually phi
in
c3 like plus one and then
epsilon plus lambda
right
but i know that this you know c3 normal
phi this is just some constant that
depends on the domain right so instead
of
uh you know having a constant phi here i
just gonna note that uh i still have
this statement with perhaps a different
domain dependent uh constant
okay and uh right i would like yeah
so you know what do i get here u is a
solution of this problem right so there
i get 0
and uh phi is the solution of this
problem so i get precisely delta so i
get delta minus c omega
u c 3 plus 1
epsilon plus lambda so this is going to
be a discrete super solution as long as
my delta is big enough right so i you
know i'm basically discovering
uh how big delta needs to be so if delta
is bigger than c
omega
okay
u c3 plus one
epsilon plus lambda and okay one also
checks on the boundary that uh
you know this
new uh
u delta
you know on
gamma epsilon is bigger equal than g so
this is a
discrete uh
super solution right
okay so that's uh so this means right by
a discrete kind of comparison principle
what i have is that uh
okay i don't want to go too low because
i know that then it's not visible
ah
right so
what we have is that uh
u
delta right is bigger equal than u and
perhaps one because again this is a
super solution and this is a sub
solution right and you do the same trick
right so on the other side so here we
have u minus uh
delta times phi minus right with a
minus you know epsilon times the
ellipse it's constant of
uh g
right okay so
uh
rate phi
is uh a smooth function so it is bounded
right so basically what we have is that
you know the difference between the
upper and the lower bound is less than
you know some constant times delta plus
epsilon right
so what we have
uh
oh and by the way note that u lies also
between those two right because
i have created them by
uh
increasing u so basically what i have is
that
u and epsilon minus u again the maximum
as it is written in the theorem right is
bounded by what we have is
2 delta well
let me write it like this so 2 delta
maximum or you know
i in l infinity
plus uh
2 epsilon times the
ellipsis constant of g but then what is
the delta that we needed right so the
only condition on delta that i had
was uh
[Music]
was
this thing over here
so let me take the smallest delta that
is allowed right so then i get that this
is less or equal than
so again i get uh
some constant so okay again u is the
solution so this is again just some
constant so i get some big constant
multiplying epsilon plus
lambda
which
is
what we want okay so there i wrote that
would be different
i mean in the end this is not so
important but i just want this uh so
okay if you now choose uh lambda to be
epsilon right then you obtain a linear
estimate right again for epsilon scaling
right so what is important is that this
works sometimes for this scale over here
okay so this
uh
right
so this
i'm not gonna get to the variational
part of our talk right so
you know we can discuss this uh this is
not actually right this you can find
let's say in jeffree there's uh calculus
variations notes in a very similar form
to what i presented
uh so
and i just wanted to kind of in general
show right how
you know the standard uh pd techniques
can be used in this random setting
the other side would be how can the
techniques from calculus of variations
also be used in this standard setting
right so
there is this uh so these pd techniques
they give you quantitative estimates but
if you're just interested in whether
minimizes converse to minimizers then
there is this notion from calculus
versus called gamma convergence which is
appropriate here and i just mentioned
one thing so there you do not get
quantitative estimates just from gamma
convergence
but the advantage that you get is that
those variational techniques work
basically in the setting okay again i'm
neglecting logarithms so one or n two
one over d
and uh
that is actually quite nice you know you
can
you can get that uh you know solutions
to
equations like this actually converge
without having point-wise consistency
right so you know we show that even for
if you take a smooth function you need
it at least uh you know epsilon to be
bigger than one over n to
uh one over d plus two to have any
estimate right yet for variational
techniques because you know for this pd
i can write down a variational
formulation right as a minimizer those
variation techniques go down all the way
to here and in for most of the problems
right let me just say that this is
really kind of a hard bond okay
logarithms can be discussed but uh
this bound here is kind of hard because
uh that is the typical distance between
neighboring points if you take epsilon
less than that most of the points will
not have any neighbors within this and
you're not recovering any of the
geometry so going below this is
ridiculous right you know then you're
not having any geometry in your graph
uh again okay you know here i'm
neglecting logarithms then you know what
does this much bigger means right but i
would say in terms of scaling this is
kind of the the hard bond so somehow
these variational techniques go all the
way to this kind of uh hard on
okay so uh
that's that's all that i'm gonna do
today thanks
[Applause]
any questions
i guess at the start we listed the lower
bound on your density so at first i
thought this was more of like a
saturation
yeah i mean if the density is zero then
the typical distance in my sample may be
bigger than this length scale right so i
would need to adjust this length scale
right uh so that i still have something
so it may be you know that uh right if
you you know i don't have some algebraic
decay and i choose some different uh
scaling over here then my graph will
still recover the geometry based on your
sparse data so that is possible so it's
not you know yeah it's not kind of that
it is fundamentally kind of not working
but one needs to work with uh length
scales which are then adapted to the
fact that you have very sparse regions
do you also need the lower dot for like
the
[Music]
uh well you know if my pd right so you
know if my graph is disconnected and so
on right then i i will not have
uniqueness and so on right so i have i
see a lot of problems right if the graph
is not connected so yeah i would say yes
right
i really like this barrier function
approach but in this simple linear
setting wouldn't it have been easier to
sort of just look at the difference of
the graph in the continuum function and
then see that it solves the graph the
graph personal equation and then use
some boundedness
for that equation well
i
would say that's kind of similar right
kind of thinking right
because
right there's a particular reason that
that you use the barrier approach here
or is it to incorporate the boundary
conditions in easier fashion
yeah i don't know it's kind of hard for
me to to say you know this
this kind of was the first thing i i
thought of so uh right
so
so here you went straight up to actually
show the convergence of your uh first
order conditions to something you know
what is the energy converge to like i
mean what is the like what is the limit
so you start with the discrete problem
and you say let's go to the continuum
like what is it that i'm soldiering
actually in the first place like let's
say i'm sampling like is there like some
energy that makes sense that i'm
actually minimizing the first place yeah
yeah so the you know the epsilon level
right so this would be you know
uh precisely you know
and double sum okay and then one half
right so
okay
yeah yeah i mean okay u i minus u
squared in a continuum energy
would be uh
just uh the integral of rho squared uh
gradient of u squared
yes okay now what is the relationship
right so that would be this gamma
conversion so
basically you know as n goes to infinity
and epsilon stays above okay now i'm
making this precise so ln of n over n to
power one over d be bigger than two
right then this uh
e and epsilon
the ammo converges okay i didn't say the
full thing to e in this tlp topology
right because
the problem is that naturally right
these functionals are posed on different
spaces right so this imposed on a
discrete space
and this is called in a continuum space
right and kind of for gamma convergence
you need all of them to live in one
metric space i mean this can be the
standard setting and this can be done
by looking at your metric space so your
metric space i don't know
uh
so it's y b
the set of pairs where the first
component is a measure and the second
component is a function so where f
lies in l2 with respect to nu so you
have this big space right which contains
both the discrete setting where this
would be a discrete measure and the
continuum setting very easily continue
measure
so you need to put the right metric on
the space and then you can recover the
gamma convergence okay so before talking
about how let me ask you why
actually i i
recovered the same thing and i thought i
made a calculation error
like
why does it make sense to minimize this
so you said okay so i understand in the
discrete case that's what people do but
like why why should i have not a row in
there like i mean it sounds
yeah so okay here is my kind of point of
view on all of this right i feel that we
should do all of the modeling in a
continuum setting right and then on the
graph you just see what is the
appropriate discretization of what you
want here so somehow on the continuum
right is the right way because that says
if i have the full information this
would be my decision right and there
ought to be some statistical reasons
right so when i look at the spectral
guide here right so this is telling me
that it's cheaper to cut in sparse
regions maybe that's statistically good
maybe it isn't right you know it's for
someone to analyze and decide but
basically on this level you can make
sense of what does it mean how does the
geometry of the data right which i can
measure i don't know in some way you
know in a way that needs to be defined
right how does the geometry of the data
uh you know relate to
what is the product of the procedure
based on this functional versus some
other and so on right and let's say you
know nicholas uh and franca and banda
right they have their paper where they
look at you know how does the spectral
clustering uh relate to
uh relate to the geometry of data on
some you know this is all at the very
rudimentary level i'm actually surprised
that there aren't more studies of of
this precise uh question
yeah because this would give you that
you started by saying there's no
axiomatic definition of a cluster
well i mean that's pretty eczematic
right it's like this is a cluster yeah
yeah here you chose your model right
yeah
okay
all the time so we could reserve the
question for the speaker and the break
so let's thank the steep okay
[Music]
you